this is the singular time I'm going to
address this because it is setting me
over the edge the rhetoric in so many of
my comments about childhood trauma and
healing and whatever you want to say
about
my family my life my parents whatever is
not your business Betty Gosselin has a
strong message for all the haters online
as is the case with every other person
in the entire world it is not anybody
else's business what they are dealing
with behind closed doors if they don't
want it to be your business the 22 year
old daughter of former reality stars
John and Kate Gosselin posted a Frank
response to a tick tock user's comment
about her famous family Maddie defends
herself and her seven siblings by
pointing out that they are no longer on
TV yet the public comments continue to
affect them perpetuating The Narrative
that we are damaged or that we are
crazy child stars or whatever you want
to say is extremely harmful as myself
and my siblings are going out into the
world and will be functioning members of
society with careers my siblings are
doing so well they are all amazing
people they're all smart they're all
kind they're driven students they're
working hard they're funny they're
stylish
you miss them oh of course I miss them
that's why I post things on my Instagram
like throwback you know TV TBD so it's
it it's bittersweet but now the other
four being adults maybe they'll realize
what the truth is and what has
transpired and maturity sets in Maddie
and her family became public figures
after appearing on 11 seasons of their
reality show John and Kate Plus Eight
and Kate Plus Eight which ended in 2017.
it's unfortunate our marriage failed but
our family shouldn't fail you know and
I'm always going to be there for my kids
no matter what I'm very
grateful
for the opportunity for the Memories
For The Memories on tape E.T recently
caught up with Maddie's younger brother
Colin who has been living with his dad
John and his fellow sex tuplet Hannah he
claims they haven't spoken to their
other siblings in about six years I
haven't reached out to them they haven't
reached out to me
um you know I don't know I I want to
respect their space and their time and
respect how they feel about everything
so I'm kind of just waiting for the day
that you know we're either they reach
out or you know I don't want to reach
out I don't want to invade their space
I'd rather just let them do it on their
own terms and while Collins says they
haven't been in contact he only had kind
things to say about his brothers and
sisters I love my siblings I mean I
would be willing to put my parents aside
and I have and in my eyes it's me and my
siblings and
you know I love them to death I love him
very much and you know kind of how I see
it is without parents involved it's just
me and them and
I really hope that you know one day when
I have kids that you know my kids will
know their Aunt uncles as for Maddie she
captioned her post saying she's received
hate mail since she was six years old
pleading with people to instead practice
kindness the internet shouldn't be just
a free-for-all where you can bully
everyone that you see decorum and
kindness should still exist in comment
sections and you shouldn't say things
that you wouldn't say right to my face
[Music]